[Musique]
dans la vie
dans la vie comme dans les films il y a
les numéros un et les numéros 2 je vous
demande de faire un triomphe pour le
seul qui a bien voulu le faire cédric 6
heures
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bonsoir je suis je suis
très émue évidemment d'être avec vous
cyril ce soir et le césar du meilleur
costume est attribué à gilles verdez
j'essaie de pas pleurer j'en rêvais ça
fait des années que je me bats pour ça
il ya une seule personne que j'aurais
remercier ces photos merci chéri tous
ses essayages de perruques de costumes
le week-end à la maison a gagné chérie
je te ramène bercy et le césar du
meilleur acteur est attribué à mathieu
delormeau être acteur c'est être soi
mais devant une caméra
paul eluard remercier cyril hanouna qui
croient en moi qui d'ailleurs m'a
proposé d'animer ce n'est que de la télé
partir du mois prochain
merci beaucoup et puis pour le reste
juste vous dire que je vous aime et que
ça se saurait où le mettre merci
beaucoup merci et naïma l'a fait quoi
elle n'a rien fait l'année l'inverseur
ce que c'est l'adversaire de géraldine
29 février
marçais
à l'école secondaire le jardin
si vous faites plus que moi je vous
offre un cadeau si vous faites moi n'y a
pas de cadeau à berlin gay coût 1
alors je vous invite à quoi a joué au
paddle avec moi c'est bon ça va me
coûter 25 balles on frappe comme et
débriefent de la cérémonie des césar et
en fin d'émission on verra on reviendra
sur toutes les polémiques bien sûr qu'il
ya eu autour des césars et on a kiffé
réponse car dieu soit loué
on fait partie comme s'il y avait une
polémique sur koh lanta tf1 n'était pas
au courant bas nous c'est pareil
voilà c'est exactement pareil vous
prenez ça voilà nous on a un événement
par an c'est les césar et marc peux vous
dire là on va le faire enfin un
événement qu'il en ait plus ils ont fait
de la provocation entre eux en donnant à
polanski
eric il le dit 12 nominations vous
attendez quoi d'un film qui est nommé
douze 12 x qui est nominé dans 12
catégories avec 23 millions d'euros vous
pensez qu'il va rien à voir le film
adèle haenel 30 secondes allers venues
dans la salle elle est venue c'est très
bien il a fallu être courageuse est
resté jusqu'au bout elle était nominée
elle elle était à 2 heures recevoir elle
était nominée pas allaiter pas nominé
alors j'ai actionné ciel meilleure
actrice si on lui avait dit à meilleure
actrice
adèle haenel est ce qu'elle va chercher
son prix mais le flou cassé les dents
mais tout le monde à tout le monde à
subventionner sa france 2 france 3
canal+ et tombe sur une jeune femme
ravissante les petites roues ce qu'on
voit là qui me dit un masseur t'inquiète
pas on aura la peau de ce violeur et
dont je lui dis ben non moi j'ai mots
que j'ai adoré le film c'est ce qu'on
entend là et là-dessus instantanément il
ya quelqu'un qui crie derrière creps
elop et il ya une autre jeune fille
qu'on n'entend pas et qui dit derrière
tu mérite d'être violée c'est là que je
reviens et que je dis maintenant j'ai
été à toucher durant 5 ans enlevé les
trois fois donc je pense avoir gagné le
droit de dire que j'aime ce film j'avais
souffert bien évidemment ma dernière
tentative de viol c'est ya quatre ans
par st james à 8 heures du matin près du
centre équestre où le mec est arrivée ma
ceinture et par derrière c'est mon sens
fait des crâneuse mais je vous garantis
quand le mec arrive vous soutient le
bras les mains ne pouvait strictement
plus rien faire il m'a couché ma mère je
voyais passer des camions les airs météo
personne ne me voyait j'ai une cicatrice
dans beau parce que mon dos
appuyez sur la cicatrice pendant pendant
deux heures le monsieur n'a pas réussi à
des braguettes et une amie ce partout
ailleurs dans les yeux dans les oreilles
dans la bouche et où j'étais glacé
sauf que j'ai un truc qui me sauve c'est
que j'ai quelque chose qui fait
exactement comme dans un l'hôpital vous
avez le tout le secteur qui sautent
l'électricité qui sont là vous avez un
blog secours qui se met en place
et ben moi quand je suis tétanisé j'ai
un respect ça m'est arrivé plusieurs
fois j'ai y compris quand j'étais petit
j'ai un espèce de truc qui se met en
place et qui agit littéralement à ma
place qui fait que je garde un sens fois
du début à la fin ça quand même duré
deux heures et demie j'ai des conseils
vraiment tétanisé oui j'étais
complètement tétanisée sur le sol et
après j'ai eu qu'une envie c'est de
rentrer chez moi me doucher et aller
retrouver mon mari qui rentrait de
haute-savoie isabelle ya plein de gens
qui sont qui viennent vous viennent en
soutien aussi jolie sur les réseaux
sociaux et qui disent qu'ils sont très
peiné par ce qu'il espère parce que s'il
ya que les mères c'est que la jeune
femme qui s'est cru autorisé à porter
les juste besoin de fonds franchement
c'est à désespérer de la nature humaine
et on connaît depuis de nombreuses
années pour savoir ce que vous allez
donc vous arrêtez de vous prendre la
tête avec ça va vraiment en fait le
petit bisou syrie
est-ce qu'ils aient un endroit insolite
vous avez déjà un coup de foudre à un
coup de foudre non mais une relation
dans le boeing 777
yahia l'oeil à la cabine des hôtesses
qui est au dessus la bosse non non c'est
pas la moitié de ce temps 47 ça mais et
donc c'est une idée à l'euro ils vont se
reposer
ouais il ya un vrai lit non et donc les
j'ai eu la chance d'aller dans cet
endroit avec un avion avec une hôtesse
dans ce lit a dans ce livre et vous lui
avez montré votre ses créations je vais
montrer mon sens cette soirée et cette
visite tapez 1 et 2 et elle a bien tapé
non la direction a demandé h comprennent
la température de tous les gens qui
allaient être en plateau afin de
renvoyer chez eux ceux qui sont trop
malades
tu es donc prendre la température de
tout le monde avec ce qu'on appelle le
pistolet 21,9 mais en vain
37 78
[Musique]
[Rires]
tous les coups un métier que je fais
vraiment c'est important vers 11h15 36,8
à 21 ans 12 en direct n'est plus
l'animateur qui vous parle et c'est
l'inspecteur baba depuis plusieurs
semaines un membre de l'équipe
déguisé en taupe s'amuse à faire des
crasses à ses petits camarades
sherlock holmes watson et moi j'ai mon
boubou
la sauvegarde on est là c'est encore un
bonheur de travailler avec rouge et
tombe au bout amenez moi le deuxième
indice au facteur g deuxième indice j'ai
bien répéter après vous arrive je viens
de dire de me nommer dacquois là mais
non le deuxième il faut pas que cela oui
d'accord
s il est vrai nom pareil à cannes a dit
ça bah oui parce nationale tu as
travaillé dans kent
là tout étant souple
[Rires]
jamal
[Applaudissements]
raymond
[Rires]
voilà il en quatre
m'emmener bogo we call et moi sans
cellule de dégrisement soit passé par
son bas de jabra dit jeffrey
il faut que je suis venu dire s à la
juge encore une enquête grandement
menacée mis les menottes quand même mais
là on est plus fort que moi
[Rires]